political berlin at the turn of the year
is a ponderous place the present
parliamentary term is more than halfway
through the current coalition of
Christian and Social Democrats continues
but it's clear this is a loveless
marriage unloved by the voters Angela
Merkel is still Chancellor more than a
year since stepping down from leading
her party she remains by far the most
popular politician in Germany far more
popular with the electorate than her
party and as the end of her mandate
approaches increasingly she's
concentrated on foreign policy goals
such as over the conflict in Ukraine
often does and Dicker's we have a lot of
work to do
but my feeling is there is good will to
resolve difficult questions and this
good will is always needed if you want
to solve political problems but there's
little sign of that goodwill on the
domestic front her preferred successor a
neglect camp calamba has struggled in
the spotlight recently calling on
colleagues to back her or sack her as
party leader in the end she got the
endorsement she wanted but faced renewed
questions over where she stands
politically I was not entirely clear
where she wants to steer the party but
it's clear that many have question marks
whether she has what it takes to be
Chancellor the Christian Democrats fear
a twin challenge from right and left
how to clawback voters who deserted them
for the far-right alternative for
Germany in recent years once
simultaneously steering a course which
can keep them in the political center
for in 2019 a green wave swept across
the country propelling that party to
around 25% in the polls and allowing it
to make life increasingly difficult for
the present government the Merkel era is
clearly coming to an end and a new era
begins and the question is who is
setting the course for this new era we
want to help set the course we are
campaigning to be the ones to shape the
new era and so Germany finds itself in a
peculiar position right now 2020 is a
year in which the politicians can draw
breath far enough away from the general
election for the main parties to prefer
to stay in government but close enough
for them both to worry about who will
lead them into that election an angular
Merkel remains the unlikely glue that
binds them together for now
dominic kane al jazeera berlin